[Music]
[Music]
so now we call aegyo salaam we do this
beauty - how you doing daddy i'm d'lai
great it's like you've been a Hum Dil
accident you're enjoying Chicago yes
definitely I always enjoyed on the Windy
City now I heard you got into some good
conversations before you came here
alhamdulillah it was a very interesting
how a young Muslim who accepted Islam in
January through the use of social social
media Facebook and YouTube you know
happens to be a follower of the work
that we do and to be able to impact
someone and then realize that they you
didn't realize that you've been your
impact in these individuals you're doing
the work for the sake of Allah and it's
beautiful to see to see the
manifestation of the work in people that
you are serving and you unaware that
you're serving so you think it's a
blessed opportunity that we came to
Chicago for for the amjur conference to
join the other Imams and to discuss
contemporary issues related to Dawa and
these incidents that occurred or these
situations that presented themselves
whether in the restaurant whether in the
message whether outside of the message
these our opportunities that naturally
came to place were unexpected not
planned but they were they felt so full
you weren't always most
tell me we've had you on before we did a
program kind of going over your whole
story but just in a summary what had you
accept Islam what was it about Islam
that had you culture basically a the
impact of the Quran when I befriended
the Quran the impact that I had and what
it what it offered me of solutions to
many different of solutions to many
different challenges as a youngster
growing up in America that I experienced
I found that the Quran the Quranic
remedy was the solution and trust in the
Quran impacted me to to the point that
didn't leave me with no doubts but to
accept the way of the way of Islam the
way of life which is Islam that Allah
prescribed for us through the Quran now
if someone says look that's just another
you know religious scripture you know
you have the Christians who have the
Bible you have the Hindus the Vedas and
whatever the scripture just like to each
his own what what would you say I mean
why is the Quran so unique are all these
books all these religions from God of
course all of the Quran confirms that as
well the Quran confirms that their
prophets that are mentioned by name and
there's those that are not mentioned by
name their scriptures that we know about
and there may be scriptures that we do
not know about but what gives us
searches in the Quran is its
preservation the Quran being preserved
for let's say 13 years in Mecca and then
and then 10 years in Medina
so basically fourteen hundred and fifty
years approximately no Quran has been
preserved so the Quran itself is the
sole purpose for the Arabic language to
be preserved so it's not vice-versa
Lupul the Quran being preserved for
anyone who wants to study Arabic and if
they will you go ahead and say if they
really want to get
the benefit of the Arabic language one
literature that is recommended is to
explore is the Koran so the Koran what
distinguishes the Quran from other
scriptures even though the Quran tells
us that we should honor that we should
recognize that that that God revealed
different scriptures but the what
distinguishes the Quran is that the
Quran is preserved in difference from
the other scriptures that that's not the
case where many of the Bible's have been
changed by the hand of human beings
there's still some truth that it can
change we can't say that all of the all
of the scriptures are false or they're
all corrupted because we will not be
doing justice to what the good that
Allah revealed that still remains in it
but if a person goes to that which is
pure which is the Quran uncorrupted
Allah says in Surat in surat al-kahf
allah says al hamdulillah leve Angela
Allah
Abdi Hilke tada well I'm hallo Hey
whatcha all praise is due to Allah the
one who has revealed the book and placed
therein no crookedness and then the word
that follows after all ye men meaning it
stands on its own the Quran doesn't need
somebody to support it no now you want
you weren't I mean you're not Arab
you're actually what's your background
Berto Rican you're Puerto Rican yeah and
you speak in Arabic which is the
original language that it was revealed
in if someone goes back to what we don't
have what was given to Jesus peace be
upon an Aramaic we don't have anything
in Aramaic that you can sit and recite
in Aramaic even if you wanted to home
but we do have what you're saying the
Quran which is preserved in the Arabic
and you're Puerto Rican and reciting
that's a miracle itself that's I would
say that's a favor of Allah upon me and
upon all those who were blessed with
learning the Arabic language which is a
tool I won't say that the learning of
Arabic language is to make you an Arab
but the learning of Arabic language is
to understand or to come to interact
with the poor
and in the way that it was revealed now
miraculously historically we find that
majority or a great number of scholars
of great reputable scholars in Islam
have ended up being non Arabs yeah
like a minimal Buhari non-muslim they're
all from different lands but they
learned the Quran they learned the
sciences and they contributed further
for this cause now myself being a Puerto
Rican I love being a Puerto Rican I love
my arroz con habichuelas I love the
culture that's my culture but the filter
of my culture is Islam that's my
priority because at the end of the day
submitting to God's will is what would
give me the salvation and so because of
that I chose to not be at the mercy and
may Allah reward all of the brothers and
sisters and those in the past who strove
hard to translate a lot of the works to
the best of their ability but I I wanted
to be able to interact with the Quran
the way it was revealed to the Prophet
all awesome let's stop right there the
way it was real to last a final measure
priorities be upon him by accepting him
you accepted Moses Jesus Ava all the
preceding prophets so you're not doing
anything new you live in the same way of
life yes which you said you wanted to
submit your will to the crater that's ie
that's Islam and then the filter went on
about this filtration system we come
back here to be in show don't go
anywhere let us follow in the footsteps
of an limine the trustworthy and be
trustworthy ourselves but as following
the footsteps the problem Hamid peace be
upon him and be kind merciful giving and
charitable morally upright and of noble
character obliging to our neighbors and
fellow citizens let us follow in the
footsteps of the greatest men who ever
walked this earth the message is that
God Almighty sent like Abraham Moses
Jesus and Mohammed peace be upon them
all who all called people to worship the
Creator alone and not his creation take
a moment now
and fulfill one of those qualities and
that's of giving towards the Dawa
something all these great Giants did and
call people to do help us reach our
yearly goal from a Down help be part of
sharing the truth support the detail
back here on the Dean show now before we
left we talked about the filtration
system we know that there's a lot of
things in culture that are good now
you're talking about like you know Islam
how is it elaborate on that how is it a
filtration system so basically if you
say that yes okay in Islam in Islam we
islam teaches of that culture is part of
the signs of allah languages is part of
the signs of allah since without the
room when they mentioned that and from
among these ayats his signs is your
different languages and your colors so
these are the signs of Allah so anyone
that says you know reject everything
that's part of your language your colors
your culture you know this is from Allah
that's what we have to accept that but
at the same time we have to also
understand our religion or Islam and
culture has several aspects which is
which is a little bit different than
then in general Islamic Sciences so
there is there is a subject of Islamic
culture which one is you learn Quran
Quran history report and number two you
learn the Sunnah number three here in
the serie the story of the Prophet
number four you learn the history and
number five you learn the language so
all these elements compose the Islamic
culture so now understand we have a
responsibility to learn it but at the
same time we should not just learn one
and neglect the other so I being a proto
Rican American Muslim I accept each one
of them and I have a responsibility to
learn my Spanish language to polish
myself up to learn my culture my Puerto
Rican culture as I have a responsibility
to polish my English to polish my
American culture as well as I have a
responsibility to learn my Arabic
language and learn my Islamic culture
what's like a popular food in the Puerto
Rican culture Oh Rose qua which will
arise and be rice and be rice and now
no prob with rice and beans but also
with that rice and beans part of the
culture might be that what kind of other
amenities caloric and so that's where
the coat the filtration says no eggs
right yes how about some some alcohol
they go to alcohol exactly so we can
drink so I say that's where it's not
it's not you it's the creator saying
this is not good for you cut it out
we see all the evil so what we do is we
look at it in a way that we can drink so
much like we can drink all types of
drinks
except alcohol okay and ideally it gives
you a lot of options you can eat all
types of meat all the right rice all
right and maybe slow down a lot of
carbohydrates on the rice right I know
of course now now that you made a very
good very important point which is that
even though you can eat all types of
food you still have to be eat healthy
conscious of Allah - hell yeah because
taking care of your health is a sacred
trust
yeah so I like it's a filtration system
now for what you can eat obviously and
it's not so many you mentioned the pork
eat everything I do other kind of meat
the alcohol and we can see you know
there's nothing at the crater obviously
limited that it's not harmful for you
one of the greatest things now I mean is
there a lot of like Saint worship a lot
of superstition that's not the
filtration system that will take or stop
and we only turn our direction of prayer
and everything to the one who created us
yes so for example in our culture in our
Latino Hispanic culture we have that
common because of the ancestors also
they came from some parts of Africa
right they brought in some of the we
call Santeria which is like the white
magic so you have the different saints a
saint for the rain and the same for
money so in Islam we only ask God right
only God that said how you said in
Spanish those deals only yeah deal only
deals so now so we we filter that yes we
have a need we won't turn to other
except God we only submit to God's will
we only like the Prophet
upon him told his son and this is good
for for learners for newcomers for new
Muslims the Prophet gave a beautiful
advice to his cousin and he said ya
volum o old child if fidella yeah vodka
preserve Allah and he will preserve you
now just this meaning and the hadith is
longer but this meaning has that if you
preserve Allah if you preserve Allah you
preserve the prayer you preserve the
will do you preserve your chastity you
preserve your tongue and your senses
if you preserve all these aspects that's
how you preserve Allah and Allah will
bless you with two things in the dunya
Allah will guide you and in the
Hereafter Allah will preserve you by
forgiving your sins and answering you
empower this is according to the
explanation of it bandaged up
I wanted to share that we're going to
take a break so keep mentioning Allah
and some people that's foreign to him
but I had a guest and he actually showed
that people just unconsciously they
actually say Allah in the puerto rican
the latin language we'll be right back
and guess how they've done
that'll go anywhere I've never seen this
before I've never done this for you wait
okay so I got a I got a nice nice little
hole there to help no fake food no fake
from now on the only real future fresh
raw eggs from a very healthy happy
chicken I know these chickens it's the
Warriors way huh well you don't have
like the warrior way the ultimate fast
food and great nutrition
back here on the Dean show and we're
with our brother Danny and happy to have
you back and you have you kept saying
Allah
you know people when they're talking in
the Puerto Rican language they say what
do they say deals how do for the God we
say deals but sometimes when we want to
say like inshallah that means God
willing yeah God willing we'll want to
say God willing insha'Allah we say oh
haha I mean it sounds like a law in
there hey yeah greater yes Oh holla so
oh hey how do you say that oh ha ha oh
ha ha
oh Allah yeah o Allah Allah yes and
we're not even Muslim now but you're
Latin speaking Spanish speaking and you
Latino Satan and typically you say it
similar to as Muslims like for example
if I say I'm going to see you tomorrow
like say I'm going to see you tomorrow
Oh holla right I hope like it got the
wheels we understand it as if God wills
yes I will see you tomorrow so that's
the beauty of this so many Latin words
in the Spanish language that go back to
Arabic and it links us to the oneness of
Allah like the siesta that the midday
nap that was a religious practice that
the Prophet taught his companions so
that they can be able to wake up in the
middle of the night to pray and we in
our in our countries we do this year our
grandfather used to go siesta
yeah the steep rod tell us something
else that the Hispanics community they
because I see this I mean there's a big
flocks of Latinos coming to Islam what
else today what do they resonate with
them that it connects them back to their
roots with Islam I think basically
everyone is is yearning for certainty in
their connection with the Lord that's
number one number two the sense of
community coming to America we get
involved in a lot of work and sometimes
we break away from our families in our
communities so now I wanted to just
share something very interesting that
we were blessed this January we'll open
in the Islamic Spanish Central Islamic
oh and nal hamdulillah we have a masala
and we have a weekly classes and it
became naturally an environment where
parents will come to take classes on
Sunday they bring their children and
informed in a Sunday School so
alhamdulillah we are providing these
services now we have the week the hood
buzz in Spanish every week and worldwide
people are seeing them and in places
where they don't have access to visit a
message this is in Spanish in Spanish
and and they are saying we we appreciate
from in Argentina in different countries
the same
we appreciate your contributions and
subhanAllah we are just doing it because
it needs to be done we're putting it
online and hoping to benefit people and
that's been amazing are a lot of people
outside now in these different places
because there's a lot of brain
brainwashing going a lot of people a lot
of false propaganda and you know as soon
as you say Islam people you know think
some crazy radical you're going to turn
into some suicide bomber and yes do are
Latinos more open to see this is a lot
of just false propaganda against Islam
those are actually the most peaceful
people out there yes see like Latinos
that Latinos that immigrated to this
country they they know about the history
and they know about the different ways
of using that the media is used for but
to proclaim particular messages so we
have found a different response when we
did a class I mean a we give material
education whatever in the flea market we
fought and majority of the people in the
free market Latinos we find the response
amazing that people are saying thank you
for giving up this material and honestly
we didn't find no backlash they didn't
come with misconceptions they said this
is interesting thank you so we just
trying to educate you so alhamdulillah I
think that yes the the me
they do their job and there is some you
know we don't want to generalize there's
a lot of good also coming out and
sometimes out of the negative propaganda
creates an interest in people and it
ends up people sincere individuals start
searching so I think that it is a
perfect opportunity to use the media to
do the work never lose hope in doing the
work and trust God trust Allah and Allah
what is the main message that you would
reach out to the people Latinos who are
tuning in and watching and what's the
main thing that you know you think would
interest them about Islam for them to
motivate them to look into it further I
think what Islam offers as a way of life
a way of life for the individual for the
family for the community for the society
for the city for the state I think that
it should be taken in consideration but
with the priority of being connected to
God being connected to Allah no Saints
no single middlemen no middle profession
box only straight to God asking God
seeking help from God seeking
forgiveness from God trust in God the
law says whoever puts his trust in God
he will suffice him sorry say that in
Spanish quien Bunga su confianza años el
sara suficiente para ellos they can
understand that right yes yes yes all
right so any suggestions any closing
comments for the Latino community out
there ah I will say please go to the
YouTube page of Islam in Spanish
subscribe subscribe to it not not for
the sake of subscription subscribe to it
because we have live programs and you
want to get the notification of these
programs that are free of charge
we have sometimes full-day seminars
about we do about prayer about worship
about different aspects of the religion
so take advantage of this and share it
with others even if you are not
spanish-speaking know
that in America in major cities Latinos
are becoming a majority and your duty as
a Muslim is to for the sake of Allah to
proclaim this message and the way you
proclaim the message is you take the
initiative to subscribe and you share
the good with others and trust God and
may allah accept from you and from
promise all thank you very much for a
lot of patience by the rotation on the
command console on Hajj Allah help us
reach our yearly goal from a dad healthy
part of sharing the truth support the
detail